hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so we're going to talk about
in this video is how to find the
derivative of a constant so if you're
watching this video probably just
starting off into calculus and you're
trying to figure out what all this is
about so I want to just break this down
real simply for you in this video when
you take the derivative of a constant
think of this as an equation like if
this is y equals 2 when you look at the
line y equals 2
we're looking at a horizontal line okay
like that and when you think about a
derivative what ad Riveter really is is
it's an equation or it's a formula okay
for finding the slope okay of the
tangent line to the graph at any point
along the graph well what you'll notice
from your previous math classes is that
when you have a horizontal line what's
the slope of the graph always it's
always zero right so when you take the
derivative of a constant it's going to
be zero because the slope anywhere along
this line or this graph it's going to be
zero so that's why we say the derivative
of a constant is zero now you could
write this out a little bit more
formally you could say dy DX so for
example if you start off with y equals 2
dy DX equals zero and all that just
means is dy is like the change in Y over
the change in X right so you know that's
that's from your slope formula right the
rise over the run is going to be zero so
I'll just show you one more example say
you have like y equals 4 okay you're
just going to have again a horizontal
line like this the slope is always going
to be zero so if you had the derivative
of 4 it's just going to equal zero now
when you're doing problems if you check
out some of my other videos about
derivatives you know a lot of times
you're going to have something more like
this like the derivative of 3x plus 2
well the constant remember a constant is
just a number it doesn't change it's
always staying - it's not like a
variable where it can change depending
on what X is but this part here when you
go to take the derivative of 2 that
part's gonna actually just cancel out
because it's going to be 0 so you don't
have to write it so I hope this helped
you get a little head start here on
learning about derivatives subscribe to
the channel check out some of my other
videos and I'll see you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon